these storefronts are American companies
that have had to leave Russia they Now
operate under very similar branding and
sell very similar products but
ultimately they're not Starbucks or
Dunkin Donuts
the mass Exodus of foreign Brands and
life under sanctions have changed things
for the Russian consumer a lot of people
are now looking to China for goods they
used to get from the West in fact it's
so significant that xiaomi Corporation
became the number one bestseller of
smartphones in 2022 dethroning Samsung
Victoria and her sister are a good
example of people looking to Alternative
supply lines they're selling neoprene
vests after companies like Billabong
left the market they identified a
company in Guangdong Province and are
now selling to a growing cohort of water
sport fans in Russia
um
some people compare the current
environment to the Soviet Union and its
isolation but in reality it Bears much
more resemblance to Russia in the 1990s
when the collapse of the centralized
communist system led to gaping holes and
Supply chains and left it to ordinary
people to fill in the gaps an example
from Modern Day Russia includes a veto a
listings website that's now full of
people offering to bring foreign branded
Goods to Russia from abroad in another
example one businessman is exporting
gold from Russia to United Arab Emirates
in exchange for goods but not every
sector is open to opportunism in
aviation airlines are having to ground
planes and cannibalize them for parts
and used foreign cars are selling for
more than when they were brand new and
for the Kremlin that's navigating a
declining economy Victoria's
entrepreneurship is encouraged in fact
they're calling this new era the
mobilization economy
[Music]